au fur et à mesure des années j'ai vu
les mains de mes parents s'abîmer mon
père est maçon donc ses mains sont
plaints de ciment il a des ongles cassés
ma mère est femme de ménage donc elle a
les doigts fripés par la javel et moi
pendant que j'ai étudié en fait je
voyais leurs corps se dégrader par ma
faute papa ils n'ont pas fait subir ces
deux pour eux c'était des sacrifices
parce qu'il voulait mon bonheur il
voulait que je réussisse mais moi je les
ai vécus comme ça c'est à dire que je
décris en me disant ma réussite être
enfin d'abîmer le corps de mes parents
parce que dès que je suis entrée à
sciences po
tous les deux ont fait des heures
supplémentaires sans réfléchir
ils ont demandé à faire des heures
supplémentaires me l'ont fait et ils ont
fait pour moi pour que moi je puisse
avoir accès à cette réussite là et quand
on on voit ses parents dans cette
situation là quand on voit ses parents
faire ce sacrifice là pour nous nourrir
on se sent redevable et on est obligé de
réussir
[Musique]
mon prof de français quand j'étais au
lycée mamie dit que c'était impossible
d'intégrer cette école donc sciences po
paris parce que il disait que c'était
pas fait pour les gens comme moi qui
n'ai pas cette culture générale et des
gens comme moi en fait ils parlaient de
personnes issues de l'immigration et qui
vivent dans un quartier populaire
[Musique]
mon premier jour à sciences po grenoble
on arrivait dans secrétariat pour
récupérer nos cartes pour récupérer nos
pulls donc ça voulait dire qu'on était
enfin étudiant à sciences po grenoble et
à la cafétéria l'inédit je me suis assis
avec des camarades et il ya un ami à moi
a donc tout nouveaux amis à moi on va là
pied ne sais pas jacques jacques me dit
mesrine tu as pris la place de ma soeur
et et à ce moment là je me dans ma tête
je me suis dit mais pourquoi il dit
cette phrase à moi dans la table et
pourquoi c'est un mois qui dit cette
phrase et je le regarde et je lui dis
c'est à dire j'ai pris la pastas heures
il me dit bah elle a passé le concours
elle n'a pas eu donc c'est toi qui a
pris sa place est en fait c'est avec le
temps que j'ai compris que jacques sa
maman était saxophoniste son père
travaille au ministère la culture donc
en fait dans sa tête j'étais illégitime
parce que j'avais pris la place de
quelqu'un pour qui sur ce coup était
dédiée à la naissance et cette phrase là
elle a été très violent parce que c'est
vraiment le premier jour mais vraiment
le premier jour de mon entrée à sciences
po grenoble et
et c'est allé mais rester dans la tête
pendant tout mon parcours et j'en ai eu
d'autres des remarques mais celle ci je
n'oublierai jamais heureusement quand
même j'ai à sciences po ge des 15-24 que
sa ville quand même et au contraire je
trouve que nous aussi on a des clichés
sur le milieu bourgeois et du bourget à
des clichés sur nos est en fait le fait
d'en discuter
on se rend compte que finalement je
prends mes amis les mêmes choses moi
j'ai des amis bourgeois qui adorent leur
a pourtant que moi qui sont là avec moi
au concert de kery james et j'ai des
amis bourgeois qu'il déteste le théâtre
et qui déteste l'opéra enfin on se rend
compte qu'il ya plein de clichés dans
les deux classes et que c'est important
d'échanger la culture générale c'est
simplement de la curiosité c'est au delà
de fait d'apprendre plein de choses
c'est de vouloir apprendre plein de
choses et à partir du moment où on est
dans la logique de vouloir apprendre
on est déjà en train d'accumuler la
culture générale dans ma dissertation
pour intégrer sciences po j'avais cité
du kerry james qui est un rappeur c'est
ma culture générale qui avait james et
de la culture générale en fait toute
votre tout ce que vous connaissez tous
que vous toute votre culture tout ce que
vous aimez c'est de la culture générale
c'est juste qu'il faut que vous apprenez
à le mettre en avant
il faut en être fier comment vous en
êtes fier franchement vous n'avez pas un
complexe et affirme lutter en se disant
bon moi je cite kery james mee site
beethoven en fait vous avez de la
culture générale je pense que c'est
important que les 4% donc issus de
milieux ouvriers qui sont devenus cadres
qui ont fait des grandes écoles
racontent leur parcours je pense que
c'est important qu'on met en avant nos
histoires parce que justement c'est un
motif de personnes ça prouve que c'est
possible ça aide d'autres jeunes à
croire en leurs rêves ça aide a surtout
dans les quartiers populaires j'ai envie
qu'on leur prouve que c'est que tous les
métiers sont accessibles c'est difficile
c'est le mot snif snif pas c'est facile
vous allez arriver en traitement des
droits non évidemment c'est très
difficile il faut beaucoup de patience
l'ascenseur social est bloqué maintenant
il faut prendre les escaliers avec des
claquettes petit à petit feu monte
chaque marche mais c'est faisable avec
la confiance en soi avec l'aide de ses
parents l'aident financier la confiance
aussi que nos peurs nos à cordes c'est
aussi un message pour dire qu'il faut
pas rester comme chacun reste cloisonné
dans le milieu donc dans lequel était
destiné depuis ce depuis son enfance
c'est pas parce que vous avez grandi
dans un quartier populaire vous est
destiné à rester dans son quartier
populaire
[Musique]